the opening scene we are shown a
pregnant woman who is urgently taken to
the hospital during a rainstorm to give
birth later the doctor informs her
husband Greg that she tragically passed
away during childbirth he also reveals
that their baby has albinism a genetic
condition causing lack of pigmentation
Greg is then taken to see the baby who
is undergoing a brainwave test
unfortunately upon seeing the pale baby
he becomes so overwhelmed with grief
that he rejects the child as his own the
story then cuts to two decades later
where Sheriff Doug and his team are
investigating the recent death of an
elderly man at a farmhouse they
determined that the man died from a
heart attack but maybe an albino though
during their search of the house they
stumble upon an underground basement
where they find a boy in hiding despite
their efforts to coax him out he refuses
suspecting that he is scared Doug calls
upon a child's Services psychologist
named Jesse Caldwell for assistance she
arrives shortly after and immediately
heads to the basement where she finds
the boy hiding in a dark corner through
Jesse's encouragement the boy eventually
comes into the light revealing his
luminously white skin his actual name is
Jeremy Reed but he is nicknamed powder
due to his bright skin tone it is
revealed that powder has never stepped
outside the house so who gave him the
nickname after a while Jesse asks powder
why he didn't contact the police when
his grandfather passed away in response
the poor boy explains that his
grandfather warned him that he could be
taken away if anyone saw him so he
always stayed away from other people for
Education he has built up a small
library and memorized all the books
there powder claims that he can recite
each and every paragraph of all the
books he owns hearing this Jesse picks a
challenging book typically intended for
college students and asks him to recite
a specific page number to her amazement
powder recites the first paragraph of
that page without any errors afterward
powder accompanies Jesse out of the
basement and she takes him to a boy's
hostel because he is now under the care
of the state upon their arrival the
other boys are captivated by powder's
appearance as they have never seen
someone like him before later that night
while powder is having dinner at the
hostel a gang of bullies approaches him
the leader John demands that powder wear
a spoon on his nose in a surprising turn
of events powder takes the spoon from
Jon's hand and begins to manipulate it
he makes it stand upright on the table
and effortlessly draws other spoons
towards it this astonishes all the boys
present there and they assume that
powder is some kind of freak or maybe
one of his books was about magnets on
the other hand Doug returns home after
work and finds his son Steve at the door
their strained relationship is evident
as they pass each other without
exchanging a single word it appears that
Steve came to check on his ailing mother
Emma who is confined to her bed due to
cancer the caretaker informs Doug that
seeing their son has brought Emma a
sense of healing far beyond what any
painkillers could provide a few days
later powder enrolls in high school and
attends a physics class during the class
Professor Ripley demonstrates an
apparatus called Jacob's Ladder which
generates an electric current as the
machine is turned on Powder starts
feeling uneasy and begins to shake
suddenly the machine overloads and
discharges powerful bolt of electricity
directly into powder's chest this causes
him to levitate in the air horrifying
all the students present in the class
Donnelly frantically tries to switch the
machine off but to no avail so he
destroys it with a chair finally
bringing an end to the chaos in the
aftermath all the students rush out of
the classroom while powder lies
unconscious on the floor worried that he
has passed away Donald approaches him
and touches his body surprisingly the
professor experiences an odd sensation
which raises his arms hair and plunges
him into a kind of altered state in the
next scene powder is hurriedly taken to
the hospital where Donald describes the
incident to the doctor however the
latter doesn't believe it as a strong
electrical shock like that would have
typically killed the boy or at least
left some burn marks Donald tries to
convince the doctor by explaining that
powder's body constantly undergoes a
process called electrolysis which is the
reason why he lacks body hair as the two
continue discussing a nurse interrupts
them and reveals that powder has escaped
from the apparently he jumped through
the window when no one was around
meanwhile powder is walking along the
street when he comes across one of his
classmates Lindsay they engage in a
brief conversation while being observed
by a curious neighbor powder looks back
at the neighbor and informs Lindsay that
he can hear their inner thoughts however
she believes that he is simply
hallucinating due to the electric shock
following this powder continues his
journey back to his grandparents house
however he is eventually captured by
Doug and his co-worker Duncan who asked
him to get into the car returning to the
school of powder has led to a conference
room to discuss his exceptional
intellect the principal visits him
personally and reveals that his IQ test
results have come out turns out powder's
IQ is over 300 Which is far more than
that of the most intelligent person in
the world the principal announces that
he is a unique and extraordinary
individual however powder shows no
interest in such matters and simply
requests to be allowed to return home
unfortunately for him Jesse reveals that
he can no longer go back home since the
house now belongs to the bank in the
next scene the high school students
accompanied by Doug and Duncan embark on
a camping trip in the woods that evening
while the students gather around a
bonfire powder sits by himself seeing
this Doug approaches him and the two
begin talking at the same time a
thunderstorm begins and powder mentions
that he can sense the storm within
himself he expresses that when he sees
lightning he feels a magnetic pull
towards it and when he hears Thunder he
shits his pants powder recalls his
grandmother telling him it's God
although he doesn't believe it he also
reveals that his mother was struck by
lightning while pregnant with him which
appears to be the reason for his special
condition the next morning his powder is
wandering in the woods he is approached
by the bullies John and Mitch without
any reason Jon points his gun at powder
saying that he can kill him right then
and there however before he can pull the
trigger a gunshot is heard in the
distance diverting everyone's attention
they rush in the direction and discover
that Duncan has shot a deer powder is
deeply affected by the sight as he can
empathetically sense the pain and fear
of the dying deer what the hell does
that have to do with lightning when he
cannot not take it anymore he grabs
Duncan's wrist with one of his hands
while placing the other on the deer's
neck surprisingly powder transfers the
deer's sensations of pain and fear to
Duncan causing the latter to convulse
violently as the effect intensifies Jon
aims his gun at powder demanding that he
released the officer however our
protagonist simply stares him in the eye
and continues torturing Duncan enraged
Jon pulls the trigger but Mitch
intervenes in the nick of time raising
the gun and ultimately saving powder's
life in the aftermath of these events
powder is brought back to Jesse who
questions him about what transpired she
is genuinely worried about his
well-being and State of Mind however
powder ignores all her questions and
states that he wants to return home when
she it's uninsisting he becomes angry
and unintentionally unleashes his powers
causing glasses as well as the lights to
shatter he then walks away confidently
stating that Jesse won't be able to keep
him there for long meanwhile Doug
returns home and meets with the Family
Doctor Who updates him on his wife's
worsening condition and the immense pain
she is enduring although Doug doesn't
comprehend why she chooses to hold on he
believes there must be a reason the
doctor informs him that he will never
know the reason because Doug's wife is
completely unable to communicate the
next day powder is sitting alone in the
dining room When Donald approaches him
the professor reveals that he felt a
distinct energy within himself when he
touched powder during the earlier
incident in class he describes the
energy as immensely powerful making him
feel youthful again he also talks about
Einstein's theory which states that if a
person uses 100 of their brain they can
do unimaginable things perhaps powder is
able to do just that which explains his
incredible Powers Donald then expresses
his desire to be friends with powder so
that he can gain more information about
him the scared boys a bit has a a tint
at first but he eventually agrees on the
other hand Doug visits Duncan's place
and notices that he has removed all
firearms from his home despite being a
die-hard fan of hunting when asked about
the reason Duncan becomes emotional and
shares his experience of feeling the
deer's pain when powder transferred it
to him he describes it as an extremely
distressing sensation as if he himself
was on the verge of death Duncan admits
that he had been so traumatized by the
event that he can no longer bear to hold
a gun hearing all this Doug realizes
that powder has extraordinary abilities
and this gives him an idea he decides to
take the boy's help in communicating
with his terminally ill wife using
later Doug brings powder to his home and
introduces him to his ailing wife Emma
gently touching her forehead powdered
delves into her mind relaying her
thoughts to the sheriff through powder's
telepathic connection Doug learns that
his wife is holding on to life because
she doesn't want to pass away without
wearing her wedding ring and without
reconciling with their estranged son
Steve she reminds Doug of a cherished
memory from Steve's childhood when they
played together in the snow and she lost
her wedding ring hearing this Doug
recollects as Steve used to come home
from school every day and searched
through the snow in hopes of finding his
mother's wedding ring Emma then reveals
that Steve has already found the ring
and it has been kept in a silver box on
her nightstand all this time moved by
the Revelation Doug is filled with a
flood of emotions and he tenderly places
the ring on his wife's finger powder
then touches Doug's wrist with his other
hand allowing him to hear his wife's
voice overwhelmed Doug breaks down in
tears embracing his wife and assuring
her that everything will be all right in
her final moments she opens her eyes one
last time before peacefully passing away
shortly after after Steve arrives on the
scene and Doug immediately hugs him
tightly the two then finally put their
differences aside and reconcile after
years of being apart all thanks to
powder the scene then shifts to a County
Fair where powder meets Lindsay it
appears that she is the only one who
doesn't treat him differently after a
bit of chatting powder suddenly touches
Lindsay's hands enabling them to hear
each other's inner thoughts during their
exchange Lindsay learns that powder's
father abandoned him due to his albinism
feeling bad she offers him comfort and
reassures him that his face is the most
beautiful one in the world she then
abruptly kisses him catching the
attention of the nearby people
unfortunately Lindsay's father also
notices the ACT prompting him to
confront powder and subject him to
hurtful insults he also prepares to beat
up the poor boy but luckily Jesse who is
also at the fair intervenes she
apologizes on powder's behalf and takes
him away later a heartbroken powder
returns to the hostel and gathers his
belongings with the intention of
escaping back to his farm however as he
is leaving he overhears some boys
playing basketball curious he walks to
the court only to discover that it's Jon
and his gang powder doesn't want
anything to do with them so he tries to
leave but the bully John obstructs his
path and takes his hat he then dares
powder to use his powers and take it
back our protagonist can easily do that
but instead he delves into Jon's mind
and Reveals His painful past of being
abused by his stepfather it becomes
evident that Jon's stepfather had once
seized the hat which had belonged to his
late biological father and subjected him
to the same taunting that he is
currently inflicting on Powder
unfortunately this only enrages Jon even
more and he decides to take action
suddenly rain begins to pour and Jon
forcibly drags powder outside he
humiliates the Poor Boy by stripping him
naked and pushing him into the muddy
water to add color to his pale skin
unable to endure any further humiliation
powder unleashes a powerful
electromagnetic pulse in a spherical
shape sending all the bullies flying
after a brief moment everyone regains
their composure except for John
concerned Mitch checks on him and
discovers that his heart has stopped
beating he is actually on the verge of
death realizing what he has done powder
is filled with instant regret so he
quickly Springs into action and starts
administering CPR on the bully using his
powers fortunately the procedure works
and John is resuscitated back to life
this impresses all the bullies
especially Mitch and so he decides to
help him out he assists powder in
secretly boarding a vehicle that is
heading towards his grandfather's Farm
allowing him to escape without further
trouble unfortunately when powder
arrives home he discovers that all his
belongings have been seized by the bank
shortly after Jesse comes to him
offering Solace and assuring him that
she will find a better place where he
will be accepted and understood unlike
now Donald joins them as well and as
they prepare to leave they encounter
Doug and Duncan outside Jesse requests
Doug for his support urging him to let
the boy go surprisingly the officer
agrees powder has helped him reconcile
with his long-lost son at that moment a
thunderstorm erupts and powder starts
running into the field with everyone
trailing behind suddenly a lightning
bolt strikes him eventually engulfing
him in a blind flash of light the movie
concludes as the clouds unleash one last
resounding thunderous Roar indicating
that powder has once again his
pants I mean he has reached the heavens
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching